all right guys this is different kind of
video for me it's topical it's not a
review or anything like that it's just
my socks and I've wanted to make this
video for a couple days now if I don't
make this video my head is quite
literally going to pop so here we are
going to talk about this so a few days
ago a website came out with this article
where this guy I'm gonna paraphrase it
was basically someone going I know a guy
who saw Zack Snyder's cut of the Justice
League movie and it was unwatchable
which if it sounds like someone going I
heard from a guy who knows the guy that
he saw something that I have no proof
that he saw me as no privity as well but
it's really what it says that I got
trusted it's exactly what it is it is
back of the school bus rumor mill
[ __ ] and it would only be i rolling
lis irritating if it didn't perpetuate
the fan divide and if it didn't happen
with Wonder Woman also hey remember
Wonder Woman where someone came out with
like I know somebody who saw a cut of
Wonder Woman it doesn't look good any
people saw Wonder Woman it was actually
quite enjoyable granted the first two
acts of Wonder Woman are smoother than
the third act but the first two acts are
so good it makes you makes me anyway I
kind of forgive the third act I see a
lot of people saying that Wonder Woman
was overhype I actually agree with you
but overhype does not mean bad overhype
to me simply means overhyped it just
means that the movies been talked up so
much that when someone watches it it
didn't live up to the hype top and that
I'm going to say this and a lot of
people are gonna be looking Star Wars is
over hi yeah I said it I love Star Wars
the Empire Strikes Back is one of my top
two favorite movies of all time however
I know a dude back home who has never
seen Star Wars and I'm just always like
you probably shouldn't or if you dude go
into it as a movie don't go into it as
like a religion the messianic cinematic
experience you've heard it is because
it's not it's not going to live up to
that if you're thirty and you've never
seen the old Star Wars trilogy I'm sorry
it's not going to live up to everything
you've heard it's supposed to be all
your life Star Wars is a great series of
movies but keep it at that but back on
track here you see that [ __ ] about
Wonder Woman and now Justice League it's
like oh it's unwatchable
so says someone who didn't actually give
any specifics and then she just pisses
me off because it just perpetuates a fan
device and didn't always used to be that
way you could like the Dark Knight and
Iron Man they came out the same year
people like both but I feel like if I'm
observing when DC said we're going to
have it
universe like Marvel then boom it
created two factions and now they just
always have to be at war I've seen this
[ __ ] a hundred times over it's nothing
new Xbox and PlayStation Sega Genesis
Super Nintendo DC II um see you this
[ __ ] happens all the time because it's
almost like we're wired for conflict
reminds me of an episode of through the
wormhole with Morgan Freeman I love that
show it's rap now but it's all on Amazon
that's not a plug that is literally me
telling you hey you want some good
entertainment these are the things I
think about I don't think about movies
24/7 I love movies but I think about the
subjects of through the wormhole so if
you want some good subject matter to get
stoned to and think about through the
wormhole they touch on whether or not
it's in us to have to conflict with
people who are not on our side on one of
the episodes it's great because back in
the cave days when you had your cave
colony or Hut colony however you want to
see it and someone from another colony
came on your camp you had to be like
that's an enemy because it's not one of
us that had to be your default otherwise
you were probably going to get wiped out
well we have reached a civilization
point where we don't have to be like
that we can get over that [ __ ] we have
higher brain function now you can see
someone or something different to be
like yeah you know what I like that too
I like them too so while I understand
the knee-jerk reaction to be like oh
conflict you're on the other side I
conflict I don't see why people have to
perpetuate it past the knee-jerk
reaction if you give in to that [ __ ] you
were literally giving in to a primordial
limbic response and maybe it's true
maybe zack snyder's cut of justice
league is truly not good point is i
don't know and neither does the person
who wrote that first article however it
was made and people made videos about it
because it's very monetizable that's
right as US fans could inflict with each
other on know my sides better and see
yous better now DC you use better that
creates conflict which makes it
monetizable people who make videos
profit because fans fight since Zack
Snyder stepped off the post-production
process for Justice League I believe it
was in May will call that half a year
before the movies supposed to hit
theaters I'd like someone having a
reservation at a really nice restaurant
where you have to wear the button-up the
suit tie the cufflinks then when they're
only half dressed someone comes to the
bedroom and the shirts not buttoned up
the ties kind of drooped over the
shoulders the cuff links aren't up so
the cuffs are just waving around like
that when you move your arm
someone looking at that half dressed
person going you are just unpresentable
like no [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm getting ready
this is the process guys in the end this
is literally me venting this is me
ranting about this because it's a divide
that I see happening that I don't see a
need for it to perpetuate and granted I
know if I'm going to talk about conflict
among people there's more monumental
[ __ ] to talk about now I get it the fact
is I talk movies this is what I do
so that's me talking about it I don't
see why MCU fans and DC EU fans need to
conflict with each other and generally
speaking I don't think a lot of them do
I feel like it's that classic case if
you're in a library of a hundred people
and five of them are belligerent drunk
as loud idiots that's what you're going
to hear that's what you're going to
notice is the loud paper so it's a small
percentage of the whole so my thoughts
on this what do you think about it any
of it whatever you think comment below
let me know as I leave you with the
words of the late great Abraham Lincoln
which is he excellent to each other and
party on dudes
[Music]